fallout continues from Joe Biden's
statement that no black person could
vote for Trump Trump has himself a very
Twitter weekend and Americans battle
over masks and social distancing I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
well I hope that you guys had a
wonderful Memorial Day weekend today's
show is sponsored by expressive VPNs
don't let others trap what you do to
keep yourself safe express it VPN calm /
man well there's nothing like coming
back from a weekend where you consider
the sacrifices made by so many on behalf
of the freedoms of this country to
realize that everything has gotten
stupider somehow everything has gotten
stupider and worse over time it just it
continues to get stupider and worse like
without end and without cease so I think
to begin we need to talk a little bit
about Joe Biden last week why because it
really has something to say about the
state of the nation because we saw a
series of stories over the weekend that
had to do with race in America and we
should all be able to agree I've always
been sort of puzzled by the notion that
we can't all agree on the basics here
here are the basics the basics here most
americans are good-hearted and not
racist hey also there are some racists
and there are people who are also just
giant jackasses who do things that
appear to be racist but not may actually
may not actually be racist they might
just be jackasses right these all seem
like fairly common sensical things also
if you're gonna blame an institution for
being racist you should be able to cite
the rules of the institution that
discriminate against somebody also if
somebody within an institution acts
outside the scope of authority and does
something racist and/or bad that person
should lose their job may all of these
things I think we should all be able to
agree on because this is just called
basic human decency at this point well
all of this has broken freshly into
public view because Joe Biden last week
decided to invoke the race issue once
more and this ties into a broader
discussion about race in America and
that is putting all the common sensical
stuff aside putting aside the ability of
all of us to agree on most of the things
that I just said the basic idea here is
that America is at root racist then most
Americans are not in fact good hearted
that deep inside the heart of most
Americans is an unspoken racism is a
bias against black Americans and that
every story that demonstrates bias is an
indicator
the great evil that is America and every
story that indicates non bias is an
outlier right what you see is the
comment and what you see is the outlier
is almost flipped in this particular
view of America okay so yesterday as
you'll recall last week when last we
left our story before you had a Memorial
Day weekend Joe Biden had gotten himself
in trouble while he went on a show
called The Breakfast Club he was talking
to a host called Charlamagne tha God and
the and the Vice President and the
presidential frontrunner Joe Biden he
said that you're not black if you
support President Trump or even if you
have to think about whether to support
president Trump listen you got to come
see us when you come to New York VP
buddy well it's a long way until
November we got more questions you got
more questions right Ellen if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're from
eard Trump and you ain't black okay now
that got him in all sorts of trouble at
least for a brief moment in time and
then everybody moved on with their lives
because Democrats decided this was not
in fact a bad thing to say in fact what
Biden said it may been kind of rough but
the reality is the what he was saying
was basically good it was basically okay
so you got two different angles here one
was that this was not a big deal we
should stop talking about Biden's gap so
- here's a montage of Democrats over the
weekend basically suggesting there's
nothing to see here that when Joe Biden
suggests that if you're a black
Republican or not actually black that
that's not a big deal
here's a here's a giant montage of
people ranging from Val Demmings to
other characters on on CNN talking about
the the non story that is Joe Biden's
comment here should have said it he
apologized for it but I really think the
goal and the murder of a president Trump
I believe that Joe Biden was incorrect
and and saying the statement you ain't
black
but I also believe that his apology was
sufficient that apology was given
swiftly he was saying I'm sorry I was
being too Cavalier I apologized to his
credit Joe Biden recognized within
minutes that he had gotten carried away
I think he has apologized and he should
have apologized it was like you know one
of those jokes that just falls flat okay
so but people were playing this as a
joke it was no big deal Jonathan
Capehart at the Washington Post today
says that it's a joke that was Jay
Johnson saying it's a joke give me
elsens or saying that it's a joke
everybody basically
it's a joke now when Trump tells a joke
it's not a joke when when Joe Biden
doesn't tell a joke it is a joke is sort
of the way this works but underlying a
lot of this is the basic perception in
radical left circles and among many of
the intelligence in the mainstream media
that basically Joe Biden was right and
when Joe Biden says you're not
legitimately black unless you vote for a
Democrat that he is basically correct
and I think that this viewpoint is worth
exploring because I do think that it
animates a lot of our politics today the
attempt to see all of politics in in
terms of racial Verity we'll get to that
in just one second because again I think
that there are two ways of viewing
politics of race one is with certain
baseline common sensical understandings
and one is that everything is seen
through the prism of America is
inherently bad we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about the
fact that the economy right now is in
shambles but there are a lot of
predictions that the economy is gonna
come roaring back sometime in the very
near future and what it does you're
gonna need a job and that means that
you're gonna need to connect with
prospective employers and if you're an
employer gonna be needing to look for
the best possible employees and this is
why you need zip recruiters zip
recruiters focus has not changed they're
still doing what they've always done
helping people find work helping
businesses find the right people for
their open rules if you're looking for a
job zipper career is working with you to
find the right job faster a lot of
predictions today one from Politico
actually that the economy is going to
move into a v-shaped recovery and a lot
of people are gonna be looking to hire
really quickly as people move out of
lockdown and back towards something
approaching a new normal if you're
actively hiring zip recruit will invite
candidates to apply to your most urgent
roles making it faster and easier to
reach the people you need by connecting
people who need jobs and companies that
need people Zipp recruiters working with
all of us so we can continue to move
forward so let's work together and
that's what zip recruiter is doing check
them out right now zip recruited comm
slash work together that is zip
recruiter comm slash work together if
you're looking for a job and no better
place to go than zip recruit and if
you're looking for a great employee no
better place to go than super clear how
convenient for everyone
zip recruit comm slash work together
okay so let's look at this perspective
so there are a couple of people who just
said the quiet part out loud and the
quiet part is that Joe Biden is actually
right that when Joe Biden says that
black people who don't vote for him are
not black that he's actually right okay
so Nicole Hannah Jones who is one of the
chief one of the leaders of the 16:19
project just won the pulitzer prize for
a an essay that had some good parts but
was horribly fact-checked and just told
open lies about the state of America and
about the history of America she tweeted
out there is a difference between being
politically black and being racially
black I'm not defending anyone but we
all know this and should stop pretending
that we don't and people responded her
they said well I'm black and I'm a
Republican so what are you talking about
and she said well if I know if you don't
know I won't tell you which is always
the remark of somebody who has a lot of
faith in their own in their own
statements here she ended up deleting
this tweet because of course it was
pretty humiliating to the New York Times
that there's a difference between being
politically black and being racially
black Jamel Hill who used to be on ESPN
now I believe she's with the ringer she
tweeted out the issue wasn't what Joe
Biden said because it was accurate the
issue is that it came from Biden it was
also clearly a joke that didn't land I'm
wondering where all this outrage was
yesterday when you all president decided
his public devotion to a declared as
public devotion to a Nazi sympathizer
I you know okay so anyway that's Jamel
Hill fairly typical the issue wasn't
what Joe Biden said because it was
accurate so I want to actually take this
you seriously because I think that this
view is worth taking seriously
considering so much of it dominates our
public debate so I think that there are
a few things we need to consider one is
race does not decide politics obviously
the level of melanin in your skin does
not determine whether you are democrat
or republican it is also true that you
could make the argument that certain
policies are better for black Americans
and certain policies are worse for black
Americans and you could do this about
any group you can say certain policies
are better for gay Americans certain
policies are worse for gay Americans but
how people decide on which values they
perceive to be important in politics
really does not have to be decided by
race so for example let's say that
there's a policy that you think is good
for black Americans like affirmative
action but you also believe that this
comes along with a lot of democratic
patek baggage that you don't agree with
and so you vote Republican instead even
if you agree with affirmative action or
let's say that you think that
affirmative action may be good for a
subset of black Americans but it is not
generally good for black Americans or
good for America more broadly right
these are all calculations you can make
so the basic idea that if you are black
and not a Democrat that you are not
black is of course incredibly silly
right Clarence Thomas is presumably
Republican the man grew up the grandson
of a sharecropper after he'd know whose
father was Thomas Sol grew up
extraordinarily poor had it lived in a
segregated area and there plenty of
black Republicans who have been fully
black right that statement is silly but
there is a sense in which you could
/ see that being that voting for a
particular party would call your your
self perception of race into question
okay the only way this would work is not
based on differential value assessments
of politics it would be when you are
under existential threat and this
explains why so much of Democratic
rhetoric why so much of wild leftist
rhetoric is about the idea that voting
is not about prioritization of values or
costs and benefits and particular
policies it's about survival because the
truth is that for black Americans for a
long time voting was about survival if
you're a black American and you were
voting in favor of Democrats who are
keeping you segregated in 1956 Alabama
there's a good case to be made that you
are not thinking about your own race
properly right and that would be true of
any race if you're a race that is under
the threat of extermination the threat
of extinction a threat the threat of
open discrimination not covert not
implied open discrimination if you voted
for somebody who said black people are
inferior right it wasn't like there was
another and and it wasn't like there
were no other choices or something okay
then you could see somebody like Nicole
Hannah Jones saying okay well that's
you're not being politically black
meaning your group is under actual
threat and therefore you have to vote
like your group is under actual threat
the problem is that in America right now
black Americans are not under actual
threat from political group now that
does not mean that there aren't
individual instances of racism and one
of the things that we need to go back to
the common sensical view of is that we
all have the ability to call out
instances of racism when we see them so
for example over the weekend there was a
woman who trended on Twitter because a
tape came out of her calling the police
on a black man and this this video was
put out by a person in Melodi Cooper
Cooper tweeted okay when Karen's take a
walk with their dogs off leash in the
famous bramble in New York Central Park
where it is clearly posted on signs that
dogs must be leashed at all times and
someone like my brother an avid burger
probably politely asks her to put her
dog on the leash then she calls the cops
so she so here is the video of this
woman and this can fairly be said to be
racist what she's doing here seems to be
a pretty obvious instance of racism sure
so this black man says to her put your
dog on the leash according to him and
then
she basically threatens to call the cops
not only did she threaten to call the
cops what's what's amazing about this
he/she is imputed to the police her own
level of racism because she says I'm
gonna call the cops and I'm gonna tell
them that an african-american man is
threatening my life
assuming presumably that the police
being brutal vicious racists at the NYPD
are gonna arrive and immediately just
shoot the black eye which of course
there's no evidence of so here is a
little bit of of the video this is a
racist incident this is a woman being a
racist even if she probably doesn't even
perceive herself as a racist because
she's probably a good Upper West Side
liberal but this is about as racist as
it gets here she is please don't come
close to me please don't come close to
me please please call the cops please
call the cops I'm gonna tell them
there's an african-american man
threatening my life please tell them
whatever you like he's recording me
myself in my dog
okay and she's getting hysterical
Lemieux while she's colouring the dog by
the way the dog ended up being taken
away from her by the shelter that that
saw this video because she's grabbing
the dog without that without the leash
she's grabbing it by the collar to
subdue it when the police arrived the
only woman remained on the scene
according to police melody and Christian
Cooper did not return messages seeking
comment on Monday night so Christian
Cooper is the name of of the man he put
out an account and he explained that
basically she was making a false report
to the police so according to the New
York Daily News according to the New
York Daily News on Monday night affirm
for which the woman is believed to have
worked frank franklin templeton
tweeted a statement she'd been placed on
administrative leave while they
investigated the incident the dog rescue
organization which was involved
abandoned angels cocker spaniel said on
its Facebook page had voluntarily
surrendered the rescue pup she
apparently has now apologized for the
for the situation according again to the
New York Daily News she says I sincerely
and humbly apologize to anyone who saw
this especially to that man his family
was unacceptable I humbly and fully
apologize to everyone who's seen that
video everyone that's been offended
everyone who thinks of me in a lower
light I understand why they do I've come
to realize especially today that I think
of the police is a protection agency and
unfortunately this has caused me to
realize there are so many people in this
country that don't have that luxury she
said that her entire life is being
destroyed right now because she's put on
administrative leave she said I'm not a
racist I did not mean to harm that man
in any way the NYPD - at first deputy
commissioner Benjamin Tucker told w/pics
11:00 Tuesday the department isn't
looking to charge the dog Lerner so
we're not gonna prosecute that we have
bigger fish to fry the DA would not
prosecute it's not even clear would be
actionable it's hard to understand why
she did what she did the fact she
invoked race is disturbing she's got a
dog the science is the dog must be leash
and in effect she was the problem so
again basically he requested according
to melody Cooper that she leash her dog
and apparently she went nuts on to him
and then she started he started
videotaping her to document the exchange
again the part of this that seems racist
is that she keeps saying that he's an
african-american man and she's gonna
call him the cops to take care of this
african-american man seems to sort of be
the implication now so I think that this
woman should be doc
on line no I don't I think that we can
all see the racism I think that she is
going to be Astro sized from her social
circles I don't think it's necessary for
everybody online to pile on to
demonstrate their virtue signaling but
again this is an example of a fairly
well-documented racist incident and
everybody basically agrees right because
when things are well documented
everybody basically agrees I'll give you
another example there's a story from The
Associated Press today a black man has
died in Minneapolis police custody after
video shared online from a bystander
Sean white officer kneeling on his neck
during the rest as he pleaded that he
couldn't breathe his death which
occurred Monday night after a struggle
with police officers was under
investigation by the FBI and state
agents Minneapolis police chief Metiria
Aaron Danzo speakings reporters on
Tuesday morning was asked about the use
of the knee on the man's neck during the
arrest
arredondo said we clearly have policies
in place regarding placing someone under
control and he said that this will be an
investigation that they do internally
apparently somebody was called to
investigate a report of a forgery at a
business which I even realized was a
thing like how do you stop a forgery in
progress police found a man believed to
be in his 40s matching a suspects
description in his car according to the
police he was ordered to step from the
car after he got out he physically
resisted officers officers were able to
get the suspect into handcuffs and noted
he appeared to be suffering medical
distress he was taken by ambulance to
the Hennepin County Medical Center he
died a short time later the name of the
officer seen kneeling on his neck was
not immediately released apparently he
kept saying over and over that he
couldn't breathe that people were saying
you need to get off his neck because he
can't breathe okay so this is an
incident where it's not clear whether it
is racist or just police incompetence
whatever it is they're gonna get to the
bottom of it and someone's probably
gonna get prosecuted
okay so again this would be an instance
where everyone basically agrees right so
the common-sense view of this is that
America is overall not a racist place
that when people are racist and there's
video of it people go nuts on Twitter on
social media becomes a national story
that when an incident happens in
Minneapolis there's a full investigation
and there should be then when there's a
cover-up people are gonna lose their
jobs in the auto in our barrier case
over in Georgia I promise you that da is
that the original da is gonna be maybe I
mean if there was corruption hauled up
on charges
people are being tried for murder so
what does that say about the state of
America well it says that Joe Biden is
wrong right because black Americans are
not under existential threat from
Republicans the argument that Joe Biden
was was innately making which is that
black Americans have to vote for him
because they are under existential
threat
from Republicans that's not true but
that's not stopping the media from
pushing a continued narrative that is
absolutely free of common sense and
that's particularly true when it comes
to covin 19 and that's the the next move
in Kobe 19 I've been predicting for for
literally months that this is the
direction the media we're going to move
and eventually they try to rationalize
Kove in 1908 sitting everybody
particularly older people we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about the fact my kids get me up so
damned early in the morning my kids got
me up this morning at 5:30 in the
morning and I was after my baby kept me
up till midnight last night so I'm I'm
tired and I'll be honest with you I
cannot wait to climb on my helix sleep
mattress tonight because my helix sleep
mattress was made just for me helix
sleep has a quids it takes just 2
minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper hot
sleeper buddy like a pleasure firm bed
with helix there's no more confusion and
no more compromising helix sleep is
rated the number one mattress by GQ and
Wired magazine sienna and called the
most comfortable mattress they've ever
slept on just head on over to helix
sleep comm slash men take their
two-minute sleep quiz they will match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
they've got a 10 year warranty you have
to try it out for a hundred nights at
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders for our listeners get up
to 200 bucks off at helix sleep comm /
Ben again that's helix sleep dot-com /
men for the best mattress on the market
I know it's personalized to me it's
extremely comfortable and since I value
my sleep more than ever these days you
should to go check it out helix sleep
calm at /ban for $200 off your order
helix sleep calm / pens as I say the
media have tried to take the underlying
Joe Biden narrative which is that if you
are Republican you are threatening the
lives of black people and then extend
that into kovat 19 because Donald Trump
is president and Barack Obama more
presidents let me just explain if Barack
Obama were president there would still
be a disproportionate number of black
and Hispanic Americans dying some of
that would be for obvious medical
reasons namely that obesity is is a
massive issue it is particularly large
it's huge among whites soon bigger among
minorities in America and obesity is a
massive confound when it comes to kovat
in 19 also there's an article from Fiona
Mitchell over in The Lancet which is
again kind of the Medical Journal of
record talking about how vitamin D
supplementation is a key here that
people who
get enough vitamin D have been
experiencing serious symptoms of
coronavirus not only not only art does
that mean that if you're older and you
don't get enough vitamin D that it could
have a real problem for you according to
The Lancet quote data from the UK Office
for National Statistics shows the black
people in England and Wales are more
than four times more likely to die from
Kobe 19 than our white people is that
because of American racism so we keep
hearing from the media as we'll see is
that black Americans are dying at a
higher rate than white Americans because
black Americans were victims of racism
and continue to be victims of racism
there's an entire article in The New
York Times today blaming slavery for
differential rates of death from Kovach
19 um then what about Britain why
exactly are black people in England and
Wales four times more likely to die from
covin 19 well The Lancet suggests black
and minority ethnic people who are more
likely to have vitamin D deficiency
because they had darker skin seemed to
be worse affected than white people back
home at 19 so in other words medical
reasons would likely explain the
differential this by the way is also
true of maternal mortality not with
regard to vitamin D but with regard to
obesity rates and premature birth and
maternal mortality rates are very very
different between black and white in
America they're also vastly different in
Europe nobody ever seems to go across
the water and notice the racial
disparity which would seemingly remove
American racism as the unique cause of
these sorts of disparities that doesn't
stop the New York Times from running a
piece today called it's not obesity it's
slavery we know why cope in nineteen is
killing so many black people so you're
gonna have to explain why slavery which
technically entered in the United States
in 1865 is going to have to is going to
have to do with the differential rate I
mean 1865 last I checked was a hundred
and sixty years ago you're gonna have to
explain to me why that has to do with
differential rates and Sabrina strings
doesn't really bother just sort of says
that it's not about obesity she says if
she says the era of slavery was when
white Americans determined that black
Americans needed only the bare
necessities not enough to keep them
optimally safe and healthy and set in
motion black people's diminished access
to healthy foods safe working conditions
medical treatment and a host of other
social inequities that negatively
impacts health okay can make this
argument in like 1880 you could even
make this argument during Jim Crow you
make this argument in 1970 probably you
can't make this argument in 2020 there's
now 55 years since the Civil Rights Act
at some point you're going to have to
say maybe people should just eat
healthier
maybe personal habits have something to
do with differentials with with with the
differentials because let's be real
about this if you are if you are a
healthy young black person you're dying
of this at the same rate as a healthy
and white person if you're an unhealthy
white person you're also dying at the
set of higher rates in other words
looking at the racial confound is that
as though that is the key indicator is
not right looking at the medical
confounds is the key indicator would be
right but this plays into the Joe Biden
narrative which is that if you were
president black people would not be
dying at a higher rate which of course
is silly and Barack Obama would make the
same argument and then if pointed if
we're pointed out that by the way people
are going to die at the same rates
regardless because the situation on the
ground is the situation on the ground
then you just blame historic racism
which of course is connected with the
evils of today's Donald Trump you play
this intellectually dishonest game where
you say slavery equals Donald Trump
they're for slavery led to this
therefore Donald Trump is leading to it
right now and this is why this New York
Times piece argues despite the lack of
clarity surrounding findings one
interpretation of the disparities is the
idea that black people are unduly obese
which is seen as a driver of other
chronic illnesses and is believed to put
black people at high risk for serious
complications from CO vat19 these claims
have received intense media attention
according to CDC forty two point two
percent of white Americans and forty
nine point six percent of
african-americans are obese researchers
have yet to clarify how a seven
percentage point disparity and obesity
prevalence translates to a two hundred
and forty percent 700 700 percent
disparity in fatalities experts have
raised questions about the rush to
implicate obesity and especially severe
obesity well what about the the other
issues in the vitamin D issues what
about the fact that diabetes tends to
run higher in the in the black community
what about eating habits right not
everybody who is obese has exactly the
same sort of medical issues in other
words trying to blame this on slavery is
a bit of a stretch and then of course
this person in the New York Times blames
the 16:19 project so this is the goal
here the goal is that in order to target
Republicans as the root of all slate as
the root of all evil you're going to
suggest that slavery is the root of all
evil and that every outlier is in every
every bad situation America every racist
situation in America is an indicator of
deep American evil not a situation in
which you can look and you can actually
see in real time as good hearted
Americans on all sides of the aisle
condemn the racism it's easier to to
you know move into the idea that America
is deeply racist because people are
dying into Firenze old rates of Kovach
19 we're gonna get some more of this in
just one second because this would
provide Donald Trump with an opportunity
to be a unifying figure considering the
Democrats right now including Joe Biden
are trying to divide Americans along
racial lines in a time when we have a
pandemic that is hitting everybody and
when everybody is scared and we've had
the greatest lockdown in American
history I'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that when you run a business HR issues
can absolutely destroy you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations and the
regulations are getting more complex
day by day this is why you probably an
HR manager but HR managers are not cheap
an average of seventy thousand dollars a
year to hire an HR manager this is why
you need an HR service just for you
Bambi spell ba MBE was created
specifically for small business and get
a dedicated HR manager craft HR policy
and maintain your compliance all for
just $99 a month with Bambi you can
change HR from your biggest liability to
your biggest strength your dedicated HR
manager is available by phone email or
real-time chat from onboarding
determinations they customize your
policies to fit your business and help
you manage your employees day to day all
for just $99 a month month-to-month no
hidden fees cancel anytime
you didn't start your business because
you felt like you know I just want to
spend tons of hours on HR compliance let
Bambi help get your free HR audits today
you can't afford the risk of not having
your HR an order go to Bambi comm slash
up hero right now to schedule your free
HR audit that's B a.m. to the B EE comm
slash apparel Bambi comm slash up here
I'll go check them out right now
okay so Democrats have been forced to
focus on the race narrative again
because Democrats are worried that the
economy is going to recover that's not
me making some sort of speculative
argument that's an article in Politico
it is called the general election
scenario the Democrats are dreading
written by Ryan Lizza and Daniel
Lippmann neither one of them are right
winger in early April Jason Furman a top
economist in the Obama administration
now professor at Harvard was speaking
via zoom to a large bipartisan group of
top officials from both parties the
economy had just been shut down
unemployment was spiking and some
policymakers were predicting an era
worse than the Great Depression the
economic carnage seemed likely to doom
President Donald Trump's chances of
re-election Furman tapped to give the
opening presentation looked into his
screen of poorly lit boxes of frightened
wonks and made a startling claim we're
about to see the best economic data
we've seen in the history of this
country the former cabinet secretaries
and Federal Reserve chairs in the Zumba
were confused Firmin said everyone
looked puzzled as though I'd misspoken
he then laid out a detailed case for why
the months preceding the November
election could offer Trump the chance to
brag truthfully about the most explosive
monthly employment numbers in GDP growth
ever this makes perfect sense if you
artificially shut down the economy and
then the economy springs back to life
you're gonna see massive numbers right
if the economy dumps 40 percent and then
month-on-month you see a 10 percent
increase those are gonna look like
massively explosive numbers a former
White House Obama official says quote
this is my big worry asked about the
level of concern Montag party officially
said it's hi hi hi okay first of all you
shouldn't be concerned about the
recovery of the economy should be
celebratory about the recovery of the
economy the fact that Democrats are
concerned that there may be a v-shaped
recovery is pretty unfortunate it is not
only unfortunate it also means that
people are suspicious that Democrats are
going to artificially tamp down the
economy in order to ensure that Donald
Trump isn't reelected I mean it's hard
not to draw that conclusion when you're
saying you're deeply worried that the
economy may recover in a v-shaped
recovery the economy would recover much
faster than during the Great Recession
Fuhrman said the Trump argument will be
he's producing the fastest job growth
and fastest economic growth in history
if he has any ability to do nonce he
will say we're not there yet reelect me
to finish the job the Biden argument
will be the unemployment rate is still
12% even with those millions of jobs
we're still down 15 million jobs and we
need new economic policies but if you
see it as a massive recovery that is
damaging to Democrats so this is why a
lot of Democrats are moving into the
sort of territory of of race first of
race first okay well what that leads to
that gets president Trump a pretty good
opening here right all president Trump
has to do to win reelection and there
there are some polls out by the way from
CNBC showing that President Trump is
still doing fairly well in the swing
states in a hypothetical matchup among
all the battleground voters surveyed he
has a 48 46 lead over Joe Biden the
scoring to CNBC on May 20th forty ones
of 30 to edge among independents
Democrats and Republicans in Arizona
Florida Michigan North Carolina
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin basically
have Trump running a little bit ahead so
that is a narrow lead and he's leading
among independents and he is leading
Biden 51 to 40 in terms of who would do
a better job handling the economy well
it seems like a pretty solid base to run
on when you add on top of
the widespread American perception the
widespread American agreement that we
are not at root a racist country that
America is actually filled with
good-hearted people who are willing to
call out racism and the Democrats racial
narrative starts to fall flat too so
yesterday was Memorial Day and President
Trump spoke on Memorial Day and he
talked about the national anthem and the
national anthem uniting us now if
President Trump were a unifying figure
this would be a great pitch it would
because the fact is that most Americans
still believe in the national anthem and
the American flag and in fact that so
many Democrats have gone out of their
way to express sympathy for people who
kneel for the national anthem is a big
electoral loser for them and is not a
winner for them here's President Trump
talking about this yesterday every time
we sing our anthem every time it's
rousing chorus swells our hearts with
pride we renewed the eternal bonds of
loyalty to our fallen heroes we think of
the soldiers who spend their final
heroic moments on distant battlefields
to keep us safe at home we remember the
young Americans who never got the chance
to grow old but whose legacy will
outlive us all okay so all of that is
good stuff and then president from
yesterday of course when he laid a
wreath at Arlington the media totally
missed covered this because Trump then
went golfing a little bit later in the
day and so they showed pictures of Joe
Biden at Memorial Day at a local
Veterans Memorial and then they just
opposed that with Trump coughing but
Trump did go to lay a wreath at
Arlington National Cemetery people were
giving him flak as wasn't wearing a mask
whose outdoors was six feet from
everybody else that was not really the
issue we'll get to the masking issue in
just a second which has become
shockingly partisan but the President
did go to Arlington yesterday okay so
all of this would be a good opportunity
for Trump right just politically
speaking oh this is a good opportunity
for Trump Joe Biden is trying to claim
that Republicans are an existential
threat to black Americans that they
literally I mean that is the underlying
message that he is providing echoed by
Nicole Hannah Jones echoed by Jamel Hill
right that is the message and on top of
that they are deeply worried about the
economy
so all Trump has to do is say listen we
brought you the best economy in American
history up until coronavirus when we
come out of this there will be a spike
in the economy it's gonna be great
well you don't need is fundamental
remaking of American society right
that's his reelection pitch instead the
president has Twitter and I gotta say
it's just it's in
facility of the highest order on a
political and moral level to do with his
Twitter what he does it is stupid it is
stupid I understand a lot of people like
to Twitter I don't frankly care I don't
care because the people who love his
Twitter are not - people who are not
gonna go to the polls anyway you're not
the people he needs to win you're gonna
vote for him anyway you know what's not
useful in a time when you are running
against a deeply divisive opponent like
Joe Biden and he is he's deeply divisive
he's trying to run as a unifier he is
not Barack Obama was a deeply diss
unifying president when in a time when
Democrats are openly worried about an
economic recovery for Donald Trump to
get on Twitter and then fulminate over
Joe Scarborough and suggest that Joe
Scarborough is a full-on murderer
question how in the world is that useful
how and not only useful how is it moral
how is it decent like what what's the
pitch make me the pitch
give me the elevator pitch for Donald
Trump needs to tweet about Joe
Scarborough murdering an intern like it
seriously what is the actual argument
here so between that had a hell of a
Twitter weekend you're the President of
the United States in the middle of one
of the worst situations in American
history grow the F up grow up do better
and I understand there people out there
say well he's never gonna do better yeah
this is what he is got it
that does not relieve you or me of the
obligation to call out immorality when I
see it not only in morality political
malpractice on the highest level
because if you believe in a lot of the
Donald Trump agenda in terms of stuff
he's doing policy wise you need to root
for him to stop this bullcrap it's
insanity they're gonna get some more of
this in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that right now pretty
terrible time to go to the post office
especially when you can be saving time
and money by not going to the post
office you don't need to go to the post
office instead you need stamps calm with
stamps calm you can print postage on
demand skip those lines and crowds over
at the post office plus you can actually
save some money with discounts you can't
get at the post office and if that
wasn't enough stamps come also offers
UPS services with discounts up to 60 62
percent no UPS residential surcharges
here at Daily wire we've been using
stamps calm since 2017 no more wasting
our time stamps.com brings all the
services of the US Postal Service
directly to your computer in the safety
and comfort of your own home office or
anywhere else
bring down right now whether you're a
small business sending invoices and
online sellers shipping out products or
you're just working from home and you
need to mail stuff
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official US postage 24/7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just leave it for your mail
carrier schedule a free package pickup
or drop it in a mailbox no human contact
is required is indeed that simple like I
said with stamps.com you get great
discounts - five cents off every first
class stamp up to 62 percent off
shipping rates stamps calm is a no
brainer
especially now saving you time and money
keeping you safe in these insane times
right now my listeners get a special
offer for week trow free postage digital
scale without any long-term commitment
it's a four week trial go to stamps com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in Shapiro that is
stamps.com
enter Shapiro stamps comm enter Shapiro
okay so we're gonna get to president
Trump's busy and insane Twitter weekend
a complete not only waste of time
completely counterproductive we'll get
to that in just one second first listen
up getting the double tumbler is back
and better than ever but it is only
available for our most exclusive
membership tier the all access the all
access membership tier is our premier
level of membership all access members
get to participate in all access live
our brand new interactive programming
featuring one of us daily wire host as
we hang out with you each night all
access members also get to join us for
real-time Q&A discussions available on
both the website and the daily wire app
all access membership now includes two
of the irreplaceable leftist year's
tumblers the tumblers are literally
overflowing with tears at the thought of
this offer alone finally all excess
members get the benefits of all the
other membership tiers get an ad-free
website experience access to all the
live broadcasts and show library access
to the shows mailbags the full three
hours of the ben shapiro show and
dedicated editorials from one head on
over to daily wire comm slash subscribe
to join all access get 15% off with
coupon code Shapiro right now it's a
hell of a deal daily we're calm slash
subscribe again I'm on all access
tonight so you'll get - I got a new
t-shirt I'm very excited you know you'll
see what t-shirt I'm wearing tonight
we'll see you there backstage on
Wednesday by the way the 27 4 p.m.
Pacific 7 p.m. Eastern you can go check
that out as well you're listening to the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so president Trump had
himself a hell of a Twitter weekend as I
say this would be a time for unifying
he's got Joe Biden living in a basement
not able to string together a sentence
and claiming that black people are under
existential threat this is the same Joe
Biden who suggests that Mitt Romney was
gonna reinsulate black people in 2012
okay so this is nothing new for Joe
Biden hey and and so what does Trump
decide to do well he decides to retweet
a bunch of stuff okay so what did he
retweet well he's he retweeted guy named
John stall have never heard of saying
when I see one of these polls that has
malarkey the racist up 68 points
everywhere I'm thinking they must have
called the same 1,000 people from 2016
that said that HRC the bleep was up 68
percent so number one I doubt that Trump
even read the entire tweet right because
that's what he does he'll tweet like the
first half of the tweet HRC that the
word is skank there by the way is the
word that he retweets that which is
always a great look
then he tweets retweets John Stoll again
I know why who's on this guy's account
we just got a look at the official
portrait for the self-proclaimed
governor of Georgia she fought a tough
race kissed a lot of babies visited
every buffet restaurant in the state Joe
will be a racist if he doesn't pick her
so you got the president now calling
Stacey Abrams fat which is always an
excellent excellent look then he decided
you know it's a good idea I'm gonna
spend the entire weekend implying that
Joe Scarborough murdered an intern okay
so so for people who didn't know this
story back when Joe Scarborough was in
Congress there was an intern in his
office and she died in in one of his
congressional offices she died because
she had an undiagnosed heart condition
she had apparently some sort of heart
attack and she banged her head on a desk
and she died it's a really tragic story
this led donald trump to tweet out a lot
of interest in this story about psycho
joe scarborough so a young marathon
runner just happened to faint in his
office hit her head on his desk and died
i think there's a lot more to this story
than that an affair what about the
so-called investigator Reid's story and
then he likes to true pundit comm and
then he continues along these lines a
blow to her head body found under his
desk left Congress suddenly big topic of
discussion in Florida and he's a nut job
with bad ratings keep digging use
forensic geniuses okay that wasn't it
this morning he was back at it was the
President of the United States and just
like he said the opening of a cold case
against psycho Joe Scarborough was not
Trump original thought this has been
going on for years long before I joined
the chorus in 2016 when Joe and his
wacky future ex-wife Mika would
endlessly interview me I would always be
thinking about whether or not Joe could
have done such a horrible thing maybe or
maybe not but I find Joe to be a total
nutjob and I knew him well far better
than most so many unanswered and obvious
questions but I won't bring them up now
law enforcement eventually will question
so here's the thing when Doc Brown fell
off his toilet hit his head on the sink
he invented the flux capacitor when
Donald Trump fell off his toilet and his
head on the sink he just tweets
apparently and what in the absolute eff
is this what is this what is this
seriously this led to the wonderful
spectacle of the of the husband of the
woman writing a letter to jack dorsey of
twitter saying mr. Dorsey nearly 19
years ago my wife had an undiagnosed
heart condition fell and hit her head on
her desk at work she was found dead the
next morning her name is Lori Kay Klaus
Klaus itis and she was 28 years old when
she died her passing is the single most
painful thing I've ever had to deal with
in my 52 years and continues to haunt
her parents and sister
I have mourned my wife every day since
her passing I've tried to honor her
memory and her Mara and our marriage
as her husband I feel one of my marital
obligations is to protect her memory as
I would have protected her in life there
has been a constant barrage of
falsehoods half-truths innuendo and
conspiracy theory since the day she died
I realize this may sound like an
exaggeration unfortunately it is the
verifiable truth because of this I'd
struggled to move forward with my life
the frequency intensity ugliness and
promulgation of these horrifying lies
ever increases on the Internet
these conspiracy theorists including
most recently the President of the
United States continue to spread their
violent misinformation on your platform
disparaging the memory of our wife and
our marriage and then he asked Jack
Dorsey to delete Trump's tweets like
question how in the world is this useful
how in the world is this useful when put
aside the immorality of it it's
obviously immoral to accuse people of
murder without evidence it turns out to
be a very very immoral thing to do it
also turns out and when you're accusing
a woman who is married of having an
affair with another man without any
evidence that's also a very ugly and
terrible thing to do but put aside that
if you're a Republican and you're
thinking you want Trump reelected this
is political malpractice speaking of
political malpractice president Trump
decided to go after Jeff Sessions his
former attorney general now let's just
understand something senator sessions
or Attorney General Sessions heben the
senator in Alabama when he first ran in
Alabama he ran a competitive race by the
time he ran for re-election for like the
third time Jeff Sessions had no
opponents he was winning over two-thirds
of the vote now Jeff Sessions was not
available to run in the last in the last
senatorial election instead Alabama
Alabama Republicans decided Roy Moore
would be their candidate a guy who
allegedly was trolling the food courts
for 14-year old when he was in his 30s
okay and then he lost it to Jones
specifically because people don't like
electing people who troll the food
courts for fourteen year olds when they
are 30 years old he said Doug Jones a
Democrat ended up representing Alabama
that Alabama Senate seat is a debacle
there's no way it should be blue all
Trump has to do is just let Jeff
Sessions go back to the Senate now
there's another candidate in there named
Tommy Tuberville a former Auburn
football coach maybe he'll win maybe
he'll do great
I don't know Tommy Tuberville very well
I do know one thing Jeff Sessions has
won that race like 11 times right Jeff
Sessions is a guaranteed shoo-in victory
in Alabama that's it that that seat goes
back to red and by the way Jeff Sessions
votes a hundred percent of the time 100%
of the time with Donald Trump Jeff
Sessions was the first major American
political figure to endorse Donald Trump
the first not one of the first the first
when no one was taking from seriously
sessions did on the basis of immigration
policy alone I know that because I
remember when he did it and I know Jeff
Sessions and I know Stephen Miller and I
know all the people who are involved yes
I remember when sessions did that it was
a big shock because a lot of people
thought sessions might have endorsed
Cruz so then he becomes Attorney General
and by law he has to recuse himself well
Trump is very angry the sessions have
recused himself he suggests that Jeff
Sessions should have resigned Jeff
Sessions offered to resign and Trump
turned it down Jeff Sessions also didn't
know that the Obama apparatus was still
investigating the Trump administration
when he took office okay so this has led
Trump to tweet out Jeff Sessions over
and over about how Jeff Sessions is bad
this is so counterproductive and idiotic
again I cannot believe how stupid this
is because he's not throwing over Jeff
Sessions because Jeff Sessions isn't
gonna win the seat or vote with him he's
throwing over Jeff Sessions because he
can't put aside the petty personal
slights
like again political malpractice you
lose right now the Republicans are in
serious danger of losing the Senate
there's a very very good shot and when
January
2021 comes around Joe Biden is sitting
in the Oval Office and he has a Democrat
majority in the Senate a Democrat
majority willing to get rid of the
filibuster and gets the Democrat
majority in the House and then how's all
this gonna look it's all this gonna be
just fun and games on Twitter how about
when how about if it turns out that
Tommy Tuberville who has not been
supremely vetted turns out to be vetted
by the media in that Alabama race and
talked Jones wins a squeaker or
something
okay so Donald Trump decides he's gonna
tweet Isis Jeff you had your chance and
you blew it
recuse yourself on day one you never
told me of a problem and ran for the
hills
you had no courage and ruined many lives
the dirty cops and others got caught by
better and stronger people than you
hopefully this slime will pay a big
price you should drop out of the race
and pray that super liberal Doug Jones
and we can put that a puppet for crazy
Nancy Pelosi and crying Chuck Schumer
gets beaten badly he voted for
impeachment based on zero disgraced
Alabama coach Tommy Tuberville will be a
great senator and then Trump went on
national TV and trashed sessions again I
mean this is just like in terms of
personal loyalty forget about like
personal qualities it takes to be this
disloyal to a human being who put his
career on the line and became your
attorney by the way he was a good
Attorney General Jeff Sessions he's
actually good at his job
and he did the right thing and recusing
himself he legally had to he did not
have any other options hey Trump slammed
quote Trump slams sessions again on
national TV was cheryl atkinson like
this is just does he understand that
he's presidents of the united states and
he has a responsibility to his own
voters not to do dumbass stuff
here's Trump Jeff Sessions was a
disasters Attorney General should have
never been Attorney General is not
qualified he's not mentally qualified to
be Attorney General he was the biggest
problem I mean like Jeff Sessions put
people in place that were a disaster
they took over they've always had the
Department of Justice but they kept it
under Jeff Sessions and that the whole
thing the Russian thing is a total hoax
think of it they spent 40 45 million
dollars to investigate him it took two
and a half years they found nothing no
collusion yeah again and then Ann
Coulter of course came forth and she
blasted from she's been long alive with
the Jeff Sessions on immigration and
she's almost solely immigration focused
and she of course was the one of these
chief Trump backers in the early going
book called in Trump we trust which
always goes to show you never substitute
human for God in any sort of in any sort
of sentence it never goes well but she
tweeted out the most disloyal actual
bleep that has ever set foot in the Oval
Office is trying to lose and think the
Senate with him another Roy Moore Fiasco
so he can blame someone else for his own
mess so this is all just genius stuff
it's genius stuff again the president
has an opportunity here he had an
opportunity here and he's blowing his
opportunity even the way that he tweets
about kovat well I said the president
tweeted about kovat and again I'm not
trying to be unduly harsh with Trump I
intend on voting for the man I want him
to retain the presidency I don't want to
see Joe Biden come in and push Medicare
for all I don't want to see Joe Biden
come in and continue to play the race
card along the lines of the 16:19
project and allow all of Bernie Sanders
old staffers to take positions in the
White House as I what I'm looking for
here so Donald Trump tweeted out over
the weekend great reviews on our
handling of copán 19 sometimes referred
to as the China virus ventilators
testing medical supply distribution we
made a lot of Governors look good and
got no credit for doing most importantly
we helped a lot of great people you
might want to start with D we helped a
lot of great people as opposed to great
reviews this isn't a Broadway show dude
also like speaking political malpractice
I've been saying for weeks how is it
that Trump and the White House team have
not cut basically an ad showing every
Democratic governor saying they got what
they needed from the White House how is
that not been done yet how is that even
impossible so here's here's the reason
why this is so frustrating because as
the country reopens and as we move
closer to something that looks like a
recovery we cannot be distracted with
this kind of absolutely idiot idiotic
insane ridiculous useless I mean I just
I run out of the source words here we
cannot because guess what there's actual
good news there's actual good news
happening right now and we're missing it
because we have to cover all this
stupidity so for example piece of good
news
Scott Falchi point out cover 19 testing
in the United States continues to expand
positivity rate continues to decline so
for all of the talk about how there are
gonna be these massive spikes we're
gonna overwhelm the health care system
again not a lot of evidence of that even
Anthony pouchy who was captain lock down
five seconds ago
Anthony foul from the NIH right he says
we can't stay
down forever in fact it could be
damaging if we stay locked down forever
welcome to the club at doctor foul chi
depending upon the dynamics of the
infection in the particular state City
Region County that you're in we
certainly want to in a cautious way
reopening
we can't stay locked down for such a
considerable period of time that you
might do irreparable damage and have
unattended consequences including
consequences for help so this of course
is exactly right by the way you know
there's evidence from the New York Times
that people are not going to the
emergency room when they need to go to
the emergency room I know personally
people are not going to the emergency
when they room when they need to go to
the emergency room there are people who
are not going in for transplants because
they are afraid that they're going to
get covered and they're going to die if
they go into the ER by the way this is
not right hospitals are now encouraging
you if you need to go to the hospital go
into the hospital they have very good
protective measures for the areas that
have kovat they basically have kovat
rooms and they have covered areas of the
hospital you're not going to be infected
if you go into the general areas that
are not Cova designated and as we now
know I mean the fact is that the class
of the shut down are extraordinarily
large the Scott Atlas has a good piece
made from from Hoover Institute along
with Jon Burge Ralph Keeney and
Alexander Lipton over at the hill
talking about these shutdowns Jon Burge
professor at University of Chicago Booth
School of Business Ralph Keeney
professor emeritus in business at Duke
University and engineering Lipton is
visiting professor and Dean's fellow at
the Jerusalem Business School talking
about the economy coming back and how we
need to reopen in other words
Trump has a reelection strategy here and
it's a very obvious and open reelection
strategy and the fact that he continues
to fulminate on Twitter about Joe
Scarborough is just beyond reason it's
beyond reason okay time for some things
that I hate
so the media malpractice when it comes
to Coba 19 continues apace just because
you're seeing increasing numbers of
cases nationally does not mean that we
are seeing an increased percentage of
positives so as I mentioned before Scot
Gottlieb former FDA Commissioner he
tweeted out this morning that the
National positivity rate ANCOVA 19 test
continues to decline which is very very
good news we are not seeing a spike in
terms of ICU care we're not seeing a
spike in terms of deaths we have maybe
that'll trail a couple weeks from now
but we're not saying most importantly
we're not seeing our emergency rooms
overwhelmed and we cannot continue this
way there's a piece in the hill by Scott
Atlas and company talking about the
costs of continued shutdown he says our
governmental covin 19 mitigation policy
abroad societal lockdown focused on
containing the spread of the disease at
all cost instead of flattening the curve
and preventing hospital overcrowding
although well intentioned the lockdown
was imposed without consideration of its
consequences beyond those directly from
the pandemic the policies have created
the greatest global economic disruption
in history with trillions of dollars of
lost economic output these financial
losses have been falsely portrayed as
purely economic to the contrary
using numerous National Institute of
Health public access publications CDC
and Bureau of Labor Statistics data we
calculate these policies will cause
devastating non-economic consequences
that will total millions of accumulated
years of life lost in the United States
far beyond what the virus itself has
caused pandemics have afflicted mankind
throughout human history so far the
current pandemic has produced almost a
hundred thousand US deaths but the
reaction of a near complete economic
shutdown is unprecedented the loss
economic output in the US alone is
estimated to be five percent of GDP or
1.1 trillion dollars for every single
month of the economic shutdown this lost
income results in lost lives these
incidents are particularly severe on the
lower income population then will likely
lose their jobs mortality rates are much
lower for lower income are much higher
for lower income individuals
statistically every 10 million to 24
million dollars lost in u.s. incomes
results in one additional death one
portion of this effect is thrown
employment which leads to an average
increase in mortality of at least 60%
that translates into 7,200 lives lost
per month among the 36 million newly
unemployed Americans over 40% of whom
are not expected to regain their jobs in
addition many small business owners are
near financial
with an average estimate of one
additional life loss per 17 million
dollars Lawson income vow translate to
65,000 lives lost in the u.s. for each
month because of the economic shutdown
lives her also lost to delayed or
forgone health care imposed by the
shutdown and the fear creates among
patients
he says emergency stroke evaluations are
down 40% of the 650,000 cancer patients
receiving chemo an estimated half are
missing their treatments these
unintended consequences missed health
care amounts more than 500 thousand lost
years of life per month not including
all the other known skips care the
reason that he is using lost years of
life is because that is a better and
more specific metric than just lives
lost because if you have a lot of people
who are dying in nursing home and their
life expectancy was another four or five
months and they died five months early
that is a different thing in terms of
calculating public policy than a 30-year
old dying 50 years early or 40 year old
dying 40 years early that does not mean
that every life lost isn't immoral
tragedy but when you're making actuarial
decisions as I've said before you have
to take into account the differences
between losing five months of life and
looting and losing 40 years of life
obviously okay so then the media
continue to get this wrong Chris Wallace
went after dr. deborah birx the other
day he said he asked if they opened it
too soon if there was too much opening
too soon no there was not too much
opening too soon the evidence was that
there was not going to be overwhelming
when the healthcare system again people
are just ignoring what the original
purpose of the lockdowns was because the
goalposts have moved here is it here is
Chris Wallace a month ago you were
saying we were going to come down below
the low end of the model which is a
hundred to two hundred 40,000 to 60,000
so my guess my question is in this last
month did you underestimate the strength
of the virus did we reopen too soon did
we reopen without sufficient
restrictions
what I was saying in that briefing that
you were talking about is what that
current model was showing and that's
exactly right why is it that she's being
asked about about being a little too
optimistic but we never hear about the
Niall Ferguson model over in Britain
that was off by like orders of magnitude
yeah that's really what we should be
hearing about by the way it is not too
early to open birth says that they are
preparing for a second wave in the fall
you knew this was coming this is of
course always going to come it's one of
the reasons why lockdown was never going
to continue to be a strategy it's just
not going to be a strategy that is that
is worth doing we are preparing for that
potential fall issue both in PPE which
is protective devices both in
ventilators stockpiles and ensuring that
we're really pushing on therapeutics and
vaccines evelopment so we can be ready
if the virus does come back in a
significant way okay and that is the
plan by the way the economy is starting
to come back I mean this is good news
according to The Wall Street Journal for
economy worst of coure Novartis
shutdowns that may be over recovering
air travel hotel bookings and mortgage
applications are among the early signs
of US economy is slowly creeping back to
life you can see this by the way on just
by looking at the traffic in Los Angeles
which is up erratically you can see it
over Memorial Day weekend people were
going out to beaches people were in
general being responsible people were
wearing masks people are socially
distancing it is amazing how the the
mask wearing has become such a
flashpoint for politics at this point
again my feeling is that we should all
be responsible that we should try and
continue to slow the spread that it is
not too much to ask people to wear masks
particularly if they are dealing with
the vulnerable and there are a lot of
churches that are reopening and that's a
good thing right when President Trump
said last week that governors should
reopen churches he was right who was the
President on Friday making the
announcement that he wanted governors to
reopen churches some governor's have
deemed to liquor stores and abortion
clinics is essential but have left our
churches and other houses of worship
it's now right so I'm correcting this
injustice and calling houses of worship
essential
I call upon governor's to allow our
churches and places of worship to open
right now for this weekend if they don't
do it I will override the governor's
in America we need more prayer not less
he doesn't have a power to do that
theoretically you could have some
lawsuits filed by the DOJ and the
Attorney General could theoretically
file some freedom of religion lawsuits
but realistically speaking governor's do
have plenary control over stuff like
this with that said churches were
starting to reopen synagogues are
starting to reopen now the question is
just be responsible and again the folks
who are very very upset about
mask-wearing there's two things that are
happening one is there's a group of
people who are like I'm not wearing
masks under any circumstances because a
pansy move and I'm not gonna wear a mask
cause if I wear eye masks that just
shows it that I'm not brave and people
need to get back out there and be brave
no the mask isn't to protect you the
mask is to protect other people around
you it's not brave to expose other
people around you to possibility of
corner virus and you won't know if you
have it because 80% of people who have
this thing are asymptomatic so if you're
in an old-age home you'd wear it now if
you're with a bunch of other young
people at a pool party or something I'm
not sure that it's honestly I'm not sure
it's the biggest deal like there's a
tape that was going around from the
Ozarks of people not socially just in
saying and not wearing masks and they're
all in a pool okay they're all 18
they're all 20 they're outdoors they're
also in a pool filled with chlorine
chlorine apparently does kill the virus
so is this a great idea
no it's an idiotic idea but at the same
time is this like where I'm most worried
about an outbreak of coronavirus not
unless all those people go home and
infect Graham right that would be the
irresponsible activity if they decide to
engage this way and risk themselves that
is one thing if they decide to go
somewhere else and risk Grandma that is
completely different thing but because
so everybody is so reactionary now so
the left basically was suggesting that
mask wearing is a sign of pure unbridled
virtue President Trump for some reason
took up that challenge instead of saying
let's be responsible it's where masks
for need to wear masks let's not wear
masks where we don't instead he was like
I'm never wearing masks and so that
means that for Democrats they're now
going to wear masks as like a fashion
symbol so now we get Democrats basically
saying you should wear masks everywhere
is why if you drive around in LA you
will see people wearing masks in their
cars by themselves which makes no sense
at all or people who are walking around
at the park a hundred feet from other
people wearing masks that's just you
virtue signaling at this point that is
not a useful thing Mike DeWine the
governor of Ohio he gets this right he
said I don't I don't really understand
why there's controversy over this
wearing a mask is about courtesy if
you're within a certain distance of
human beings what we do directly impacts
others and we're not saying if you're in
a car you're driving by yourself you
don't have to wear a mask you don't have
to wear a mask if you're out you know
wait from people hiking or or doing any
kind of all kinds of different things or
in your own house but when you go out
and interact directly with people we're
asking Ohioans to do this and so it
doesn't it's it's not about politics
it's not about conservative or liberal
it's about helping other people may that
is basically correct but this has led to
Democrats being like well you're stupid
if you don't learn a mask if you don't
wear a mask everywhere you go it's cuz
you're dumb so Andrew Cuomo who couldn't
even protect the old-age homes Andrew
Cuomo over the weekend he was like yeah
you're dumb if you don't wear a mask
why you wouldn't use it it there's no
legitimate rational explanation well I
don't like the way it looks you know
what paint something on the mask right
get a new color it's not smart it's not
smart my colleague Melissa De Rosa said
yesterday it was stupid that's another
way of saying not smart sort of the high
/ New York way of saying that takes less
words okay so this turned into over the
weekend
Donald Trump goes to Arlington he's not
wearing a mask he doesn't need to wear
masks he's away from other people he's
outdoors he's also the most tested
person on earth I'm sure Joe Biden goes
to a Veterans Memorial with his wife and
he's being feeted from wearing a mask
he literally look you can see the tape
he's nowhere near other human beings
nowhere near them the reason he's
wearing a mask is because he's virtru
signaling now so this is turned into if
you take Kovac seriously you're wearing
a mask if you don't take Kovac seriously
you're not wearing a mask how about this
wear a mask when you're supposed to and
you don't need to wear a mask if you're
outdoors and Veterans Memorial you know
again this is just turned into fashion
it's a fashion thing now everything in
America begins as like a serious policy
proposal and eventually turns into a
polarized discussion about absolute
utter stupid nonsense just ridiculous on
every level here's the reality we want
to get back to work want to have that
v-shaped recovery wear the mask when
you're indoors with other people when or
within six feet of other people don't do
it when you're outdoors and away from
the people and then go back to work and
if you don't want to be with other
people and you don't trust other people
then stay home there's your reopening
policy we've done it magic
okay that's because that's exactly what
people are doing on every level right
that's exactly how things are going the
fact that everything breaks down into
prior partisanship is just insane to me
utterly utterly crazy all right time for
a quick thing that I like so my wife and
I have sort of run out of new movies
because no new movies are being made and
I happen to have seen nearly every movie
ever made at this point and so we've
been going back and watching some great
oldies or at least that's what we call
them where I'm from Back to the Future
is just you forget how good a movie this
is because it's so popular the scripts
of this movie is so good and skorts this
movie by it by Alan Silvestri is just
phenomenal it is a phenomenal score the
last 15 minutes are one long musical cue
and it is one of the best musical cues
in school in film history it's a
fantastic you everything from when from
when Marty gets back to Doc and then the
storm starts from that to the end of the
movie is basically one musical cue it is
a great cue it's fantastic
the script is is incredible Michael J
Fox he's absolutely charming the
backstory to the movie is kind of
fantastic because Michael J Fox had a
conflict when he was doing family ties
and so he actually couldn't play Marty
McFly they actually did like the first
third of the movie with another with
another actor and then they went back
and they spent three million dollars and
reshot it with Michael J Fox because
they realized that the actor just wasn't
working out try remember his name he
actually became kind of a famous actor
but the movie is great here's a little
bit of the trailer if you'd never seen
Back to the Future you're really really
missing out it's it's fantastic are you
telling me you put the time machine he's
sending Marty 30 years back in time
yeah he's trapped in the past
[Music]
originally was Eric Stoltz he's supposed
to play at this park going on to play a
lot of other parts have a fairly big
career particularly doing kind of
character actor II stuff but the movie
obviously requires Michael J Fox who
remains one of the most charming people
who has ever on a movie screen really
like think about the fact that he was a
fifty that he was a five foot five guys
24 when he played this I believe and
just the most charming thing on TV and
and I mean imagine having the biggest
turn on TV and the biggest hit movie
theaters at the same time which is
exactly what he did pretty incredible
all right we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise we will see you here tomorrow
I'm Ben Shafer this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike foramina hair and makeup is by
Anika Geneva the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20/20 joe biden informs 40 million
black americans that if they support our
president
they ain't black is joe biden a racist
is joe biden a rapist democratic
representative Ilhan omar says she
believes the woman accusing biden of
sexual assault but she's going to vote
for biden anyway and president Trump
accuses MSNBC's joe scarborough of
murdering a staffer some heavy stuff to
start the week check it out on a michael
no show
[Music]
you